I'm Reggina crib Tracy weirdin I'm hello
I'm an audio my name is big sue I firmly
believe in me and everybody's right to
have a slice of pizza pie
my name is tide I don't really care if
I'm grounded my name is Lauren lapkus
and I'm an improviser and actor
so you might know Lauren from her roles
and oranges the new black or Jurassic
world you might even know her from her
own podcast I however was introduced to
her through the podcast comedy bang bang
where she often improvises slightly
unhinged oddball characters on the 370
seventh episode of that podcast she and
Paul F Tompkins created one of the most
delightful and weird comedic moments of
the last year and it was all completely
improvised I was asleep in a vault yeah
we gotta night once we started making
money I think that's where we developed
a claustrophobia as well maybe a little
Paul F Tompkins and I have played
characters named Jasmine and Sonny and
all we decided before we recorded the
episode is that we were going to be
radio show hosts together and that we
had this morning talk show I don't know
you filled out in sunny the same you
know that those a trick question razzle
dazzle I think characters really spoke
to me because I could beat anyone and
especially because I started when I was
younger it felt more comfortable to not
play myself and to play something else
is linked totally different I'd find
voices in my car all the time and one of
the most recent ones they found was big
sue who's she talks like this shifts
Pizza a big Vegas Pete so she's always
concerned about getting another slice
she describes pizza very in depth and
then we all know what that is but but
finding that voice is really fun for me
because it's like it's a new thing that
I discovered I could do I definitely
feel like I embody characters on the
pads I'm doing a podcast a lot of my
characters have really absurd
description there's one character I
believe if I recall correctly her eyes
were extremely close together and her
butt crack was fused if Pamela from Big
Bear who is a
mess head she's got you know crazy teeth
for sure missing some of them and
there's coho the naughty elf who's the
size of a dollar bill he's a naughty elf
that works in Santa's workshop he has a
candy cane penis can I say that here
he's a candy cane penis he's evil but
lovable one of the things that gets
harder the more episodes of my podcast I
do is is finding new voices and it's
basically impossible I mean I've done
like 70 episodes now and it's a
different character every time so I have
Tracy Riordan who's a 17 year old girl
she talks like chisel rhotacism which
means she can't say hoes Regina crimp
who she's the singer of the America's
Funniest Home Videos theme song her hair
gets bigger it doesn't grow longer she
sings
we've got laughs from coast to coast she
talks like this she really is like she's
just happy about life video she lives
her car sure she lives her car
she grills hamburgers on the on the
engine some nights just to kind of heat
him up here's no microwave or anything
like that
she's pretty sad she spent all her her
money from her theme songs pretty
quickly and now she doesn't have
anything when I was in Chicago there was
a group called rag dolls an all-female
improv group they were so amazing and to
watch like a group of women just go
totally insane together and do and
follow whatever the other was saying and
totally support each other it was really
inspiring to me as I was younger it was
a lot harder for me to start a
conversation with a stranger or for
instance and I think improv taught me
how to just go with it and not judge
myself and and trust that I have
something worth saying
thanks so much for watching the video
I'm gonna put a couple of links down
below with podcast recommendations for
all of Lawrence characters we're all
super funny
they all had me in tears by the end I
was laughing so hard and it's really
some of the best comedy and improv
you'll ever listen to